[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact back in October
2012 Gilberto Arroyo a port car washer
from the streets of Sao Paulo Brazil and
not seeing his family in months
but nothing could prepare him for what
he saw when he came into his mother's
house where scores of people had
gathered when they saw him some fainted
some screamed others ran from the room
and terror why in the middle of the room
was an open coffin containing gilbert
rose body surrounded by flower petals
the family had come together to mourn
his death but it turned out to be a
bizarre case of mistaken identity
another car washer in the large
Brazilian city univee dos santos gama
had been murdered who looked exactly
like Gilberto when the police first
found the body they called Gilberto's
family and the similarities were so
striking that even his own brother
identified the body as that of his
younger sibling after recovering from
the shock the family was elated Gilberto
smotherer told reporters I am overjoyed
what mother wanted me after seeing her
son dead and then she sees him alive
friends you know the Bible tells us that
resurrections have happened in the past
and they're gonna happen again in the
future
stay with us we're gonna learn more on
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
one eight hundred four sixty three
seventy to ninety seven now let's join
our host pastor Doug Batchelor and our
co-host pastors Jean Ross
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and if you have any Bible
questions we'd invite you to give us a
call
lines are absolutely open right now we
are live here's the number one more time
God says 800 God says that's 800 for six
three seven two ninety-seven you pick up
the phone now you've got an excellent
chance of getting your Bible question on
tonight's program and that's what we
deal with any questions that have to do
with living the Christian life or the
Word of God we don't claim to have all
the answers but we've got Bibles and
Bible resources at our fingertips so
give us a call tonight one more time
lines open 800 God says 800 for six
three seven two nine seven and I'm Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross yes
pastor Doug before we go to the phone
lines we want to begin our program with
the word of Prayer dear father in heaven
we thank you once again for the
opportunity to spend a few moments in
your word we pray that the Holy Spirit
we got our hearts Lord our minds as we
search the Scriptures be with those who
are listening lead us into a clear
understanding of Bible truth for we ask
this in Jesus name Amen amen pastor Doug
it's been a few weeks that you and I
have been able to get the yellow on the
radio program and take Bible questions
and that we just remind our friends if
you do have a Bible related question
this is a good time to give us a call
our phone line here to the studio is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven eight hundred four sixty
three seventy to ninety seven you
probably have a long list of Bible
questions seen that we didn't do the
program live for a couple of weeks
hopefully in calling those questions we
are trying to answer many as we can you
know you open the program pastor that by
talking about someone you can just
imagine at first the shock
and the surprise but then the incredible
joy to discover that someone you thought
was dead a family member yes is actually
alive yeah and you know it's happened
before we've all heard stories of where
there was some mistaken identity and and
a person thought their loved one had
died it was miss identified and they
later found out that it was just a
tragic mistake
and they're live but there actually have
been times in the Bible where somebody
was completely did and they were
resurrected now you we all know their
stories where a person says you know I
died on the operating table and they
didn't technically die maybe their heart
stopped and and they passed out you know
but they weren't dead but you've got
stories in the Bible of people like
Lazarus who was dead for so long that he
already was beginning to decompose and
smell I mean he was very dead and Jesus
raised him back to life and you can
imagine the elation of his sisters when
they thought oh this is hopeless he's
been dead for four days of course Jesus
he was dead for three days and the Lord
raised him up there about a dozen
resurrections in the Bible in the Old
Testament Bible tells us that God did
the first resurrection it was of Moses
and then you've got Elijah resurrected a
boy
strangely enough his apprentice also
resurrected a boy and then you have
another man during a funeral he was laid
on the bones of Elijah he came back to
life in the life and Ministry of Jesus
not only did Jesus raised Lazarus Jesus
raised a young man on the way to be
buried he was very dead how there was a
girl that had died said Talitha koum a
twelve year old girl he brought her back
to life the Apostles most people believe
that Paul resurrected Eutychus when he
died Dorcas Peter resurrected after she
died and we've even heard stories you
know it's hard to prove it today but
we've heard stories that are pretty
miraculous of missionaries out and you
know some pagan jungle and a child died
and and they prayed and they were
revived and I've I've heard some of
these stories yeah I'm
he's like everyone else I'm a little
dubious when someone says there was a
miracle but I've heard some people I
really trust give me strong evidence
that there really was a miracle and but
the greatest resurrection is not in the
past it's in the future and you can read
about that in first Thessalonians it
tells us that the Lord Himself will
descend from heaven with a shout 1 maybe
I should say before Jesus says that he
says concerning those who are dead he
could says asleep we don't need to
sorrow as others that have no hope for
if we believe that Jesus died and rose
again we believe the Lord will bring
with him those who sleep in Jesus for
the Lord will descend from heaven with a
shout with the voice of the Archangel on
the trumpet of God and the dead in
Christ will rise there's gonna be a
great resurrection of the just the dead
in Christ rise first revelation 20 says
blessed and holy are those who have part
in the first resurrection you don't want
to be in the second resurrection because
that's the resurrection of the Lost
if you would like to better understand
the subject of life and death and the
coming of the Lord we have a free offer
for you the resurrection is often
connected with the second coming of
Jesus because at that point when the
sleeping Saints will be resurrected we
have a study guide that talks about the
second coming of Christ and also
includes this special reunion day you
know pastor Doug that's gonna be quite
the gathering families are gonna be
reunited friends are gonna meet again we
were both at a memorial service today
and of course it's one of the great
hopes of a Christian is that their
resurrection morning absolutely the
study guide is called the ultimate
deliverance and this is our free offer
for today we'll be happy to send to
anybody who calls and asks the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven again that number
is 885 six seven four seven and you can
ask for the study guide called the
ultimate deliverance all about the
second coming of Christ and that
glorious resurrection morning eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven if you have a Bible question our
phone line here to the studio is 800
four six three seven two nine seven
again that's 804 63 72
97 I think we're ready to go to our
first caller this evening we've got Tim
and he's listening in Kentucky Tim
welcome to the program all right thank
you yeah thanks for calling and your
question yeah yeah my question is I am
driving home back to Indiana from
Kentucky from my wife's grandmother's
funeral and the pastor said and I've
always thought about it when she closed
her eyes and dad he said to be absent
from the body is that being the
president's Lord so does that mean that
she's in heaven right now experiencing
heavens realm no not as far as the time
we live in now what I mean by that is
when a person dies there's no
consciousness of time until the
resurrection so for them their next
conscious thought is the presence of the
Lord and the resurrection but we know
the resurrection hasn't happened yet
jesus said the resurrection this is John
chapter 6 that occurs in the last day
they call it the day of the Lord we also
know the judgment is still future a
great Judgment Day and so because the
resurrection and the judgment hasn't
happened as far as our time they're not
there yet because when the Lord comes
the dead in Christ rise right the Lord
will descend from heaven a shout of the
Archangel the trumpet of God the dead in
Christ rise that's at the coming of the
Lord which is future so but for them we
can be at peace because we know the next
thing they're conscious of as far as
they're concerned no time has gone by
they're gonna open their eyes and have a
glorified body and it'll be the
resurrection so you see what I'm saying
it depends on whose eyes you're looking
through if you're looking through the
eyes of the Dead we can rejoice with
them their next conscious thought is the
presence of the Lord as far as the time
we live in no it hasn't happened yet
okay so does that make sense yeah yes
that makes perfect sense because it was
almost like an you know I was let me
wonder you know so right now is he in
heaven or
she you know it could was in the same
breath he said you know the dead know
nothing yes Lazarus funeral yeah Lazarus
funeral jesus said our friend Lazarus
sleeps and they said Oh Lord if he's
sleeping maybe he'll get better in LA
Jesus said no no he's dead I'm just
saying you know he's sleeping in the
Lord so even Jesus used the term sleep
to describe death until the resurrection
that's when the dead in Christ awake the
Bible tells us you know there's two
resources are on a mansion dealing with
the subject of death that I think you'd
find interesting the first is the study
guide that we have it's called are the
dead really dead and we'll be happy to
send this to you Tim or anybody who
calls an ass and are you driving but
maybe you can remember the number it's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven that's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you can
ask for the study guide called all the
dead really dead we also have a website
that deals with the subject called death
truth calm just death truth calm a lot
of scriptures great study resources and
actually some video content you can
watch some sermons dealing with this
subject so hopefully you know it's easy
to remember if you're driving just
remember the word amazing facts and then
when they get to amazing facts type in
death and we got tons of resources just
at that one
one site just go to the search type in
death it'll show you at all I think old
I can't remember numbers we're not
there's like some folks can mix Kohli's
Phil listening from Detroit Michigan
Phil welcome to the program
where are you doing good thanks for
calling and your question tonight
questions from the 6th chapter of 1st
Corinthians the 15th to the 17th verse
doesn't mean that you're straight little
harlot you become one French at that
moment the this the pain going at more
than one one or two times all right well
let's talk about that for just a second
the verse let me read it for our friends
listening because they might think this
is an unusual question but Paul actually
raises that he's talking about purity
and if you go back to verse 13 they said
you know meat is for the belly and the
belly for me it's but God will destroy
both hitting them now the body is not
for fornication now you've got adultery
is when married people break the vows by
engaging in sex with someone other than
their spouse fornication is any sex
outside of the marriage covenant the
body is not for fornication but for the
lord and the lord for the body and God
has raised up the Lord and will also
raise us up by his own power no you not
your bodies are members of Christ so I
then take the members of Christ your
body and make them the members of a
harlot god forbid what do you not know
that he that is joined to a harlot is
one body for the - he said she'll be one
flesh now here Paul is quoting where he
says a man and woman get married and in
the act of love they become one and you
know it is through of course the union
of intimacy children are born the
commingling of the DNA often produce a
new life and so you're even one in the
child sao paulo saying that's a sacred
procreative Act where a man and woman
become one and that is reserved for the
marriage covenant he said why would you
want to have your body be one with a
harlot and be one in something that is
defiling the temple it's not the
marriage covenant it's just you know
living in morally so that's that's
pretty much what he's addressing there
and I hope that helps a little bit with
your question did that help answer that
alright hey thank you yeah you're
appreciated thank you very much for your
call if you have a Bible Christian the
phone line here the studio is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven eight hundred four sixty three
seventy to ninety seven onyx Holies
Jennifer listening New York
Jennifer Yan Bible answers live good
night for good evening I don't know I
don't know what Scripture is taking from
because I'm a blind woman okay
what it said it said on anyone who said
they had no sin we deceive ourselves and
this and the truth is not in them can
you please explain that for me please
pastor Ross is looking it up I think
it's in first John he that says he has
no sin deceives himself and the truth is
not in him
it's in one of the letters of John I'm
almost sure it's either first second or
third John but I think it's first John
but he's basically saying we've all
sinned because it tells us in Romans all
have sinned and come short of the glory
of God their Bible says there is none
righteous no not one you can read in
Isaiah all we like sheep have gone
astray we've all sinned the only one who
did not sin according to the Bible is
Jesus it tells us Peter says he who did
no sin did you find a pastor oh yes
first John chapter 1 verse 8 if we say
that we have no sin we deceive ourselves
and the truth is not in us yeah so
you're part of being forgiven is you
must come to the Lord
confess your sins and repent of your
sins if a person saying well I don't I
haven't sinned you know I've never
robbed a bank I've never murdered
they're just thinking of the big general
terms of the ten commandments but Jesus
said it's not just committing adultery
it's thinking about response yeah it's
not just robbing a bank it's having
robbery in your heart or covetousness
and so sin is more than just the action
it's often the attitude as well so we've
all seen and so we must profess that
sorry go ahead I'm sorry you're asking
yes so do you think the scripture
pertaining to the past present and
future
yeah well I do think it talks about past
sins now let me give you something to
think about
when Jesus died for your sins all of
your sins were in the future at that
point isn't that right yeah yeah so when
you come to Christ and you surrender
your life to him he not only gives you
grace to cover your past sins your
present challenges but he's gonna give
you grace for your future sins now that
doesn't mean that you don't have to
repent of and turn from them and confess
him an but the power is there to not
only help you start to cover the past he
gives you grace for the future as a
pastor sometimes says God wants to save
you from the the power of sin and the
presence of sin as well and so and he
saves you from your past sense well yes
there is is there any such thing as
unknown sin a person can sin ignorant
Lee sometimes we sin because we don't
want to know and you know there are
there are people and the reason I say
that as Jesus talks about and pastor
Ross might have to look this up in sin
Luke where he says that the the servant
that knew his master's will and did not
do it he is beaten with many stripes he
who did not know his master's will and
didn't do it is beaten with few because
he just didn't know but sometimes we
don't know because we don't want to know
escucha we can find that please yeah I
think pastor Ross are looking up if
you're in the King James Version it'll
say many stripes few stripes and also
Christ said that you know we're all
responsible for not only what we know
but what we can know and that verse is
in Hosea it said my people are destroyed
for lack of knowledge because you have
rejected knowledge so it's not just what
you know if you've got a Bible sitting
on your stand and you can't read it
because you're blind well that's one
thing if you got them on film and equip
them no that's okay that's why I'm asked
that swai I'm not using you because you
you shared that way
so there's things you can't know but if
you've got Bible tapes and you can
listen and you say well I don't want to
listen then you're rejecting knowledge
so you know we can't know your pastor
Ross has that
yeah the verse you're looking at is Luke
chapter 12 verse 48 Luke 12:48 is
awaited yeah that's the one that talks
about the few scribes you guys ready
says he that did not know his master as
well so we want to know all we can and
hey we thank you very much for that call
by the way at the amazing facts website
if you can get someone to help you out
we've got tons of audio resources for
you to listen to amazing facts that's a
lot of material that we provide for
Christian Braille record services they
they do a special work among those who
cannot see and so we have a lot of audio
materials thanks for your call
next holy is Ignatius listening in
Georgia Ignatius welcome to the program
thank you so much pastor for taking my
call thank you for calling I have a
question since being christened as a
baby and one church many years ago
having been accepting Jesus as an adult
and being baptized in the early eighties
and continuing on through today I have
heard over and over again through many
denominational churches that there's a
belief that once saved always saved and
that just doesn't seem to gel right in
my mind it's being correct or there's
the business
live local answer to that well I don't
believe it's true that once a person
saved that then they can no longer be
lost and it often people get to that
conclusion by circular reasoning and
they say if you're really saved then you
can't be lost if you go to church and
you go through all the Christian motions
and then you turn from Lord well you
never really were saved so it's really
hard to argue with that kind of
reasoning because but because there's
examples in the Bible of people that
were clearly filled by God's Spirit they
were chosen by the Lord they must have
been saved and then they
earned an example would be King Saul
King Saul was chosen by God he didn't
campaign for the job he was filled with
the Holy Spirit the Bible even says he
prophesied but then he started becoming
proud after becoming King he turned from
God he grieved away the Holy Spirit he
committed suicide he most surely will
die a loss man he went to a wits just
before he died it so the idea that he
would be saved there's other verses
actually to say King Saul turn for me
and God withdrew his mercy from him so
of God withdraws his mercy then you're
lost then you got Balaam the prophet who
started out a prophet of God and he
became greedy revelation talks about
they they made the mistake of Balaam who
went after covetousness Balaam was saved
he was a prophet turned from God he will
be lost
Peter talks about a pig who's washed
that returns the wallowing in the mire
and a dog that returns to its own vomit
some pretty graphic examples of a person
who you know returns back to the life of
sin Judas was sent out by Jesus and the
other disciples preaching and teaching
and he was among the ones that were
casting out Devils many will come to the
Lord saying Lord Lord we taught in your
streets we cast out Devils we did many
wonderful works and he will say depart
from me I don't know you so now I know
some of my once safe friends will say
well they never really were saved but I
think the Bible is pretty clear that
when you have a relationship with the
Lord you need to maintain it on a daily
basis that's why we say give us this
daily bread
that's why Luke says we take up our
cross daily denying ourselves this is
why Paul says I die daily
it's a daily decision to follow Jesus
and we need to keep nurturing that
relationship if you neglect it where is
it in Revelation where he says if you
lose your first love he said I'll remove
your candlestick out of its place and
here he's writing to a church so there's
a lot more scripture on that but you
know we have know you you I don't know
if you've got yeah revelation 2 verse 4
that you have lost your first love
experience yep yep and then later he
tells one of the churches I'll unless
you repent I will remove your
candlestick out of its place so he's
saying and
see repent you're doomed and I will not
take his name from the book of life
maiming people can have their name in
the book of life and then have it
removed
that's pretty clear they were saved name
taken out of the book I think even Moses
referred to that so I'm probably giving
you more than you want but we do have a
free book that talks about can a save
man be lost would you like a free copy
of that yes I would the reason I the
question came to my mind was brother
Dortch is a seventh-day adventists Bible
study we were studying the Ezekiel after
having already gone through Daniel and
revelations and we went through Ezekiel
18 Friday night and there were just a
few verses in that chapter that brought
this question to my mind
yeah Ezekiel says if a righteous man
turns from his righteousness none of his
righteousness will be remembered and
that's that's answering what you're
talking about right there
Ezekiel 18 about this all my life and
they will talk abou streak that you know
once you accept Jesus you're in the club
no but yeah you and I know that a person
can go forward they can pray a prayer
they can say I'm accepting Jesus and
then they can go out and just and they
can live entirely for the devil but no
matter what they do they're still saved
that's kind of I think a dangerous way
to think now the reason that doctrine
developed is because there are people
who don't you know they don't want to
have a relationship where they say I'm
saved today and I'm lost tomorrow I'm
saved and then I make a mistake I stand
a boom I've lost you know I don't think
that's the way it works with the Lord I
think when we accept the Lord and he's
in our life we fall we get back up again
it's not like he's turning off and on
your salvation God's very patient with
us even Samson who was filled with the
Holy Spirit he made a whole lot of
mistakes before God took his spirit from
him and then God forgave him and gave
him the spirit again but he was very
patient with Samson he was very patient
with Saul he's very patient with us very
merciful we just don't want to presume
on his mercy
and just abandoned ourselves to a life
of sin and think we're gonna be saved
that's that's fatal so yeah that's yeah
that you know I want to send you the
book and the book is called can a save
man be lost and so if you will call our
resource number and we'll send you a
free copy the number to quite a lot
you're welcome
the number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven you can ask for the book
called Kenneth save man choose to be
lost
number again is 883 five six seven four
seven annex colace Teresa listening from
Walla Walla Theresa welcome to the
program Therese are you there Teresa
sometimes people put it on you yet okay
hi and we got a minute before the break
you want to get your questions started
oh sure I everybody always when they're
preaching a sermon they skip from books
to ebooks and around and so I was
curious as to who put the books of the
Bible in the order that they are Luke
was supposed to have written acts and so
I was curious as to why wasn't Matthew
Mark Luke acts and then John or first
Samuel where there's some issue with the
people supposed to wipe out all the
people and they saved the king and some
of the good booty and wondering yeah
you're wondering how the books of the
Bible were organized right because like
with the one in 1st Samuel where they
were supposed to wipe out all the kings
and their optimality is yes and they
saved a little bit and and the issue of
not wiping them out and after is where
their issue comes from yeah I'll tell
you what we'll do it we'll talk about
that when we come back we're gonna take
a quick break if you don't mind hanging
on the line and we'll get back to your
question just right after this break
we're gonna need a couple minutes for
station identification dear friends we
still have lines open the best of the
programs yet to come
800 God says I'll bring in your Bible
question 800 4 6 3 7 2 97 coming right
back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
amazing facts began in 1965 with a God
inspired concept
hello this is Joe Cruz on the amazing
facts broadcast facts which affect you
each radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science nature or
history followed by a Bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every walk of life the program was an
instant success and the ministry soon
began expanding to include Bible lessons
in 1986 amazing facts added the medium
of television to its growing outreach
efforts offering soul-winning
evangelistic messages for viewers around
the world
in 1994 pastor Doug Batchelor assumed
leadership of the ministry adding the
Bible answers live call-in radio program
and new ministry TV programs began
airing on multiple networks around the
world for 50 years the driving vision of
amazing facts has been the bold
proclamation of the everlasting gospel
and with a team of evangelists circling
the globe and thousands of men and women
being trained through the amazing facts
center of evangelism program Affco the
ministry is helping God's church see a
rich harvest of souls amazing facts
God's message our mission
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 phone call we
invite you to ask any question related
to the Bible the Word of God our living
the Christian life and login lines open
so a good chance you'll get your
question on second half of tonight's
broadcast we had to interrupt a question
we were talking to Teresa and Teresa had
a question about how the books of the
Bible were organized and she was also
asking about when the the command came
to King Saul to annihilate the
Amalekites and then later there was a
command where Haman wanted to annihilate
the Jews am i right Theresa there yes I
am and so you wanted to know why would
God seem to say commit genocide no I was
wondering why I like the book of Esther
even though Haman was one of the
Amalekites from their family line should
have been killed is people still living
longer and
this in a correct historical order or is
there a reason why it's farther along in
the book not closer to Samuel yeah well
Esther Esther takes place much later
than Samuel some of the Amalekites did
survive when king saul went down he said
we killed all of them except the king he
lied they didn't kill them all that's
why Haman who was an egg a guide a
descendant of King Agag the Amalekites
that's why he was there to try to
annihilate the Jews so the some of the
Amalekites lived for many generations
later they had migrated to Persia which
is how they ended up being there in the
courts of Persia during the days of
Esther but the book of Esther was
written hundreds of years after King
Saul maybe even those with historical
information as far as being the lot the
lineage from the people that should have
been it's just added information in the
story the Bible the Bible stories are
not with Matthew Mark Luke and then it
should be ax and then John because Luke
wrote ax so I was you know there again
the books of the Bible how they got put
in the order that they were when certain
things seem to seem like they should be
more connected if they were closer
together and we can understand them yeah
the the books of the Bible are not
placed in chronological order you're
right the books you've got the books of
law the books of history poetry the
Minor Prophets major prophets so
actually I got a backwards major
prophets Minor Prophets but the New
Testaments arranged that way too and
once you get to the letters of Paul
they're kind of arranged in order of
length where you've got the longest
letters of Paul Romans and they
subsequently get shorter so it's a very
simple thing you can look online Teresa
and you will find versions of the Bible
it's all the same words but they've
arranged the books chronologically and
sometimes it's fine yeah they there are
you know some scholars might disagree on
a couple of books and what order they
should go in but 90% of them agree and
you can look and find the books of the
Bible arranged in chronological order
you might be surprised to discover the
first book of the Bible would not be
Genisys it would be joke as far as when
they were written so yeah so you guys
skip around a lot and yesterday I was
listening to the past broadcast and you
said something about zest and I and it's
like three chapters and all you said was
say Zephaniah but we never went here and
read anything and we were skipping
around and I thought well I wonder why
they skip around so much when they seem
to be connected but not close together
that's all the Word of God and so the
authority is there and so you know it
even says Book of Isaiah you study here
a little there a little line upon line
precept upon precept so we're comparing
princess yeah it helps hop around so
that you can kind of figure out where to
go back to sometimes I think in the
learning process yeah well you know when
you're driving in a car that's got a GPS
that's got a satellite if you knew the
the satellites in the sky are all over
the place and they're they're
triangulating together to give you a
fixed position when we look at the Bible
it's like all this inspiration of stars
and we look at all of them to get our
position fixed we compare scripture and
book with Scripture and book and yeah
that's the way to determine truth hey we
got a free offer we'd be happy to share
with you Theresa
it's about the Bible and it's called the
ultimate resource if you'd like a copy
give us a call we'll send it to you as a
gift the number to call is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
you can ask for the book called the
ultimate resource it's actually sermon
booklet I've you know people get it and
they think they're gonna get this
900-page book I don't want to be
disappointed it's a sermon study but
it's a booklet number yam is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven that is the resource phone line
just asked for the sermon book called
ultimate resource if you have a Bible
question a phone line here to the studio
is eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven eight hundred four six
three seventy to ninety seven the next
caller is Eddie listening in Oregon
Eddie welcome to the program hi you don
doing good
are you okay yeah I'm a road driver I
was listening to you guys all the time
you know cuz I listen to one thirty one
Family Talk well good will bless you
hurt
what I was wondering is when you first
came on you they mention something about
the resurrection of Moses one of your
callers is learn about the resurrection
now is that referring to the
Transfiguration
or is there a place in the Bible were
Moses resurrection well you first of all
in Jewish tradition it well it does tell
us in the Bible when Moses died God
buried him so boy talk about having
someone you know Adam and Eve had God
conduct their marriage and Moses had God
conduct his funeral but then you go to
the book of Jude now Jude only has one
chapter so you go to Jude verse 9 and it
says that when Michael was contending
with the devil regarding the body of
Moses so we get this idea Michael has
come to resurrect Moses remember Michael
the Archangel is present at the
resurrection in first Thessalonians the
dead in Christ rise the voice of the
Archangel so Michael comes to resurrect
Moses and the devil says you can't take
him because I tempted him to sin and and
Michael says the Lord rebuke thee and
then you see G Moses appear in the New
Testament talking to Jesus obviously
he's resurrected so by doing just some
deductive reasoning
it appears Moses was resurrected by the
Lord so he could see the children of
Israel cross into the promised land he
that was the longing of his life he had
to die first resurrected him so he could
actually see the children of Israel
cross over because I know he was he
didn't get the inner end and he got to
see it yep and because of his anger or
something to that effect
he was supposed to strike the rock or
earth yeah he was supposed to speak to
the rock and he struck it twice and lost
his leg because the obstinate people
they were constantly whining pushing
them to the limits and he kind of you
can kind of understand it if you were
him but hey yeah I hope that helps a
little bit so we believe Moses was
resurrected and the Jewish people
believe that as well there's a booklet
it's an ancient book called the
assumption of Moses and the Jews say
three days after his death that God came
and raised him and it's not in the Bible
but
what you do find in the Bible is the
book of Jude and then did Moses appears
in the book of Matthew Mark and Luke on
what they call the Mount of
Transfiguration so he must have been
raised so the ones that we know of that
are in heaven
Enoch was taken to heaven without seeing
death you have Elijah thank me heaven
and you have Moses who was resurrected
and taken to heaven and then you have
the group that were resurrected at the
time of Christ's resurrection and he 27
and they were taking to him yeah and
that's about it
hey we'll send you free book we got a
book on Moses and Elijah on the Mount of
Transfiguration it's called the glorious
mount we'll send you a free copy of that
booklet the number to call is 883 five
six seven four seven you can ask for the
book called the glorious mount again
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven I next call is Jason
listening from Utah Jason welcome to the
program
hello hi thanks for calling I'm a truck
driver also listen on XM 131 we're glad
for all you guys out there and your
question tonight the text to lose me but
women teaching in the church I believe
it it pertains more of and not that
women can't teach but it's it's women
teaching over the men yes that is a much
disputed verse because like Ellen White
and and all that so yeah I don't have
anything to go look back on we've got
some verses verse thinking about he's
first Timothy chapter 2 verse 12 where
Paul writes and he says I do not permit
a woman to teach or to have authority
over a man but to be in silence and he's
talking in the context of the church
yeah and so we don't believe that Paul
is saying that a woman is not supposed
to ever teach because you've got
examples in the Bible where you have
women that were prophets you have
examples in the Bible where it says
there are four daughters of Philip that
did prophesy now they may have just been
teaching other women but if and then you
have
priscilla and aquila when here they're
given a Bible study together to Apollo
they taught him more correctly in his
theology and so there's absolutely no
question that you know we believe in the
priesthood of all believers but you
don't find an example in the Bible of a
woman serving in the capacity of a
priest apostle a pastor these were
always men in the Bible and actually
only men were called to be king in the
Bible you've got you know Queen Esther
but only the men were anointed is King
so if a man go ahead I'm sorry when I'm
talking to somebody and that comes up I
don't really have any real good way of
showing the the reasons why what Paul is
saying Paul is saying that the women
should not be assuming authority over
the men right it should be something
that is granted the godly has called the
men to be the spiritual leaders in the
family and in the church only men
offered sacrifice in the Bible they were
to be the priests of the ferrite but
many times God spoke through the woman
and told men a matter of fact even God
goes Abraham he said listen to your wife
Sarah so you know there were many times
God spoke to the men through the women
but God always respected that men such
as you know from Adam on down the
spiritual leadership was they were to
take that initiative as servant leaders
not to be you know bullies or despots
Ellen White comes up well she's not
supposed to do what she did well why not
they're women prophets in the Bible
right that's what I that's what I always
try to point out I should never assume
never called herself you know a an
ordained minister so she never assumed
one of those roles she just assumed the
same roles that you would find other
places in the Bible but you know I think
we've gotten a study that talks about
prophecy and prophets I was also
thinking of the book we have which
called woman in minister yeah that that
was about this and probably answer some
of these questions that people have with
reference the first time of the
to to verse nine well they're able to
send that to anybody who calls and asks
the number is 800 four six three seven
two nine seven eight hundred four 63 72
and 97 you can ask for the book called
woman in ministry I'll be happy to send
it to you or anyone that calls our next
caller is Marjorie listening from
Michigan Marjorie welcome to the program
hello pastor thank you I have there was
there's two things that bothers me I
always went by or tried to go by what
God's law is because I go by God's law
then man's law is making me an enabler
in my family but I did what my husband
wanted me to do and he was the head of
the house that's just the way it is and
I'm I'm below him only in the fact that
we work together for the good of the
children and raising a family and and
but God's law that's to me I thought
that was God's law but man's law if you
if you go and tell them that you spanked
your child because he did something
really really bad and that was the only
way you could get through to the child
so he would never do that again they can
take my child away from me for striking
him and yeah so right I know what you're
saying so if you're if you're having to
make a moral decision between am I gonna
obey the law of God or am I gonna obey
the law of men yeah you always put the
law of God ahead of the law of men
sometimes you're gonna have to use some
wisdom and prudence because you know
like you said you know the days were
that nobody nobody would get thrown in
jail if they appropriately gave corporal
discipline to a child but nowadays yeah
if you start saying what you think the
Bible believes not just about corporal
punishment and of course that should be
done in in mercy and gently yeah but the
you know if you start saying that I'm
two men getting married is not marriage
Oh people come on glue they call it a
hate crime and and it's the societies
God
morals are changing but we're all going
to be tested you know the last days
we're gonna have to decide do we obey
the law of men of the law God if there
are people who want to marry the same
sex I don't want to hear about it that's
their business just don't shove it down
my throat believe in it yeah well I
think most Bible Christians don't
believe in it but you know we're in a
society where that segment is just a
very militant that'd be accepted and
normalized and if you say you don't feel
that way then you're considered to be
unloving and you're called
they say you've got a disease called a
phobia just because you know you've got
a different opinion all sin you're sick
you got a phobia
oh boy am i sick if I sick think okay I
also want to know the three evil ones is
that something the beast dragon is
prophet these dragon a false prophet
yeah you want to know what are those
yeah can we send you a lesson because
that's a pretty big study we've got a
lesson we'll send you it's free and it's
called the mark of the beast
okay and so it's the beast and the Beast
is not the dragon it's the dragon the
beast and the false prophet
it's the counterfeit Trinity you know
the true training you got the father's
son in the Holy Spirit so here
counterfeit Trinity the dragon which is
the devil the Beast which is this
religious political power in the last
days the false prophet is sort of a
religious movement claiming to be
Christian but it's very much based upon
feelings and experience they're these
three entities spiritualism work
together in the last days and as past
that I've mentioned it's a very deep
study but an important one that
Christians need to understand so you
know I would encourage you
if you call and we'll have be able to
send a lesson you can also read it for
free at the amazing facts website for
anybody wanting to learn more about this
very important prophetic truth the
number to call is 808 three five six
seven four seven that is the resource
phone line and you can just ask for the
lesson called the mark of the beast and
we'll be able to send that to anybody
who calls and asks we've got Ryan
listening in California Ryan one from
the program hi yes thank you casters
Remmy on I had a question home the way I
interpreted and believe it is twice five
states and Jesus that he came he is died
on the cross and rose from the bed that
we are saved and that is the only way
not doing anything of any kind of work
like doing stuff in truth or anything
else
yeah well salvation comes first by faith
entirely by faith but then if you are
saved by faith there'll be a change in
the works because even and you know
Jesus said when he comes behold our
reward everyone not according to their
faith is that reward you according to
your works because your works show if
you really do have faith see what I'm
saying okay that's why James says show
me your faith without your works and I
will show you my faith through my works
so if if a person says I love the Lord
with all my heart but they never pray
well it's pretty clear they don't love
the Lord with all their heart you know
if the person says you know I I give my
heart to Jesus and they won't give ten
dollars to their church they probably
haven't given their whole heart so II
you know your the works are sort of a
demonstration of what's happened by
faith okay so yeah we are saved 100% by
faith that's why Paul says let every man
examine himself whether he is in the
faith so you know we look when we say
Lord you know I need to get closer to
you because I'm just getting sloppy
about my prayer life I'm getting sloppy
about share
my faiths are serving you and and I want
to love you more and so it's a good idea
for us to do a little honest
self-examination and say what's
happening with our faith is our faith
strong sure so yeah yeah yeah we are
saved by faith and faith alone that
thief on the cross will be in heaven
because he turned to Jesus and he was
saved by faith he didn't come down from
the cross and earn his salvation but if
you could pull out the nails and have
saved his life he would have lived a
different kind of life right so hey
thank you that's a great question and we
do have a book and it's talks about
faith and grace and it's called does
God's grace wipeout the law and that's
the free offer we'll send anyone who
calls an ass it's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you can
ask for the book called does God's grace
blot out the law eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven that is
our resource phone line we have Robert
listening in college place Washington
Robert welcome to the program thank you
thank you thank you you're welcome
I have just a quick question there was a
lady earlier talking about first John
where it talks about if we say that we
have no sin then the truth isn't in us
yes so if if that's true then and we
want to tell people that we need to keep
the law of God then then how can we help
you other people to keep the law of God
is if we can't keep it ourselves
well all of us have sinned
in the past the question is can we
repent and be changed and so if God
gives us a new heart and all things are
made new then the Lord expects us then
to follow and obey so do you believe a
person can keep the law I believe in all
things are possible and I can do all
things through Christ well yeah so
that's why Solomon said here here's the
conclusion of the matter this is the
last chapter
chapter 12 of Ecclesiastes fear God and
keep his Commandments for this is the
whole duty of man for God will bring
every work into judgment with every
secret thing whether it be good or evil
so over and over it talks about here's
the patience of the saints here are
those who keep the commandments of God
you know I think an important thing to
bear in mind is who do we depend upon
where do we get the power to keep God's
commandments you know when the Bible
says that there is none righteous no not
one
for us trying to keep the law in and of
ourselves
well that's futile that won't work but
if we recognize our need of Jesus and
through the surrender of self allow his
spirit to work within us both to willing
to do according to his good pleasure
well yes all things are possible to him
who believes so I think that's something
we want to bear in mind when it comes to
obeying God if we're simply trying to
obey God in and of ourselves to try and
earn merit with God to get to heaven we
will fail but if we're surrendering to
God and allowing him to work within us
well then yes there is nothing
impossible it just depends on whether
the person's had a new newly newly
created created heart kind of thing yeah
if we're born again God gives us a new
heart then old things pass away all
things are made new hey thank you very
much for your question I appreciate that
next Coley's Tim and he's listening in
Antelope California Tim you on the air
hello pastors evening thanks I had a I
have several translations of the Bible
and yeah so you're getting kind of far
from your phone I don't know if you're
on a speakerphone I'm not reaching
around my Bible has in parentheses and
this is where Jesus made all meats clean
and that's not in the Greek and it's not
in King James or New King James that's a
yeah there is one ministry arrived
they found there is a Greek manuscript
of the book of Mark I think you're
reading chapter 7 if I'm not mistaken
yes and in that manuscript
there was a parenthetical statement that
one of the translators made and those
who did the NIV translation said well
maybe that's not just the translator
making a comment or a note maybe that
should be part of what Jesus said but
it's not in any other manuscript so it's
hard to believe that Jesus said that and
declared all foods clean because when
you get to Acts chapter 10 and Peter
sees this vision of a sheep coming down
from heaven and this is several years
later Peter says not so Lord for I've
never eaten anything common or unclean
so the idea is way back and Mark the
Lord had told them that everything was
declared clean Peter had no idea of that
in 36 ad yeah this is 34 80 Wow
yeah it just didn't sit right with me
yeah you know there the statement some
some translator put that in he was being
ambitious the statement actually says in
the original that they're talking about
eating with unwashed hands it's the
whole context and Christ is saying it's
not eating with unwashed hands that
defiles you because when you eat if you
get a little dirt in your mouth it goes
through your digestive system which
purges all meats he says it's Lily it's
eliminated and when he says the word
purging all meats he just means in your
digestive system it kind of burns that
stuff out someone took that to say he
was declaring all foods clean but that's
none of the other translators took it
that way so the NIV kind of went out on
a limb on that one and I would
respectfully disagree with what they did
there okay yeah mostly I used the King
James yeah King James New King James the
new American Standard a number of others
are really good versions but hey thank
you very much for your question I think
we're just running out of all time here
and I don't think how much time we got
Steve got one minute we can't take a
question in one minute
don't but don't change channels because
we still got a couple minutes left to
tell you wonderful things you know how
at the end you save the
for last friends if you have been
blessed by this program there is a lot
of good teaching that we do you're
listening you could be listening
streaming driving down your road through
the amazing facts website you know I get
some pretty slow with technology but
I've learned lately that I can find a
YouTube or website I listen in my car
plug it into my system and you can
listen to the infinite number of things
amazing facts has an amazing library of
sermons that you can listen to download
if you watch it your computer you can
watch the videos as well now this
program is what we do one hour a week we
do television also all week long on
major networks and we encourage you to
just go to the website it's amazing
facts dot o-r-g and keep in mind while
you're there we are entirely supported
by you click the button and donate
god bless till we talk again next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G are you wondering what
lies ahead in human history or what the
recent world events are harbingers of
the end are you ready for the coming
crisis landmarks of prophecy offers
clear answers to your most pressing
questions presented by Pastor Doug
Batchelor landmarks of prophecy is a
contemporary video Bible study adventure
designed for today's audiences
presenting the landmark themes of the
Bible in a bright and compelling way
helping you understand the Bible better
and giving you knowledge to face the
future with confidence landmarks of
prophecy contains over 30 hours of
exciting video presentations on six DVDs
plus bonus question and answer sessions
giving you keen insight into what lies
next in human history if you'd like
practical tools to help you thrive and
survive in the here and now get
landmarks of prophecy start your epic
Bible study adventure with landmarks of
prophecy today by calling
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF AG 0 RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore comm which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]